the bins are finally here we're at the  storage depot novenky order where we've  got 17,000 bins to go to their new homes  starting on Monday we'll be delivering  the bins right through to late June and  there's a few things you need to  remember before you start using them  once deliveries in your area thing  completed there'll be lots of buns out  on the street so make sure you're  grabbing the right ones by checking the  label on the side of the bin the  expanded curbside collection service  doesn't start until the 1st of July so  please don't use your bins until then if  you're wondering what size each burners  you can easily check by lifting the lid  and checking the stem on the top lip of  the bin and will be delivering  information packs from mid-june letting  you know everything you need to know  about the new service including new  collection calendars learn more at  Waimakariri govt TVNZ /r e think rubbish